it's not about black friday black friday
wouldn't exist if it wasn't for
thanksgiving
two days away and for many wealthy
turkey eaters they're shelling out more
than 200 buckaroos for a bird we are not
just talking about any bird heritage
turkeys is what they're known as they
are bred with the same standards as
pedigree dogs they are named things like
bourbon red standard bronze and black
and slate they grow at a normal growth
rate their metabolical rate has not been
changed or mutated and they cost get
your head around this tk they cost as
much as 10 bucks a pound versus a dollar
60 a pound for a conventional bird
what do you make of this what does this
say about the luxury consumer because
those farmers out there they're not
really making that much more money well
if you think about what goes in to
feeding these birds breeding them taking
care of them they have huge requirements
on them they're not making more money
who is this matter to
stephanie i always say that value is in
that much like beauty values in the eye
of the beholder so heritage turkeys are
known for being much tastier okay there
are no antibiotics no steroid steroids
in them they're very scarce so there's
there's a value to be able to being able
to say i'm having a heritage turkey only
30 000 produced versus 240 million
regular turkeys so there's a lot of
value why not a higher price and you
know what because they are not
genetically modified or less genetically
modified i'm not sure but steph their
breasts aren't as big so i just like the
fact i like the fact that small breasts
are more desirable so i had a heritage
turkey on sunday night because that's
when i celebrated uh thanksgiving i
wasn't so much focused on the breast
size yes of the turkey i mean the fact
of the matter is i'd rather feed my
children an antibiotic-free bird it was
super delicious tk
i i think it goes to the luxury market i
don't think 200 is a lot to spend on a
turkey i think for a lot of people in
elite america not the upper one percent
but the upper ten percent it's just a
new thing to do but what it does go to
is aspirational america in your research
professor mohammed what do you see about
this strange word aspirational whether
we aspire to stephanie's turkey or we
aspire to a gift hold on maybe this
turkey isn't necessarily a luxury
purchase i got it as i said because it's
antibiotic-free and it tastes much
better than a turkey infused with a
needle's worth of butter at the end of
the day you like what you like i think
stove stock
stove top stuffing is delicious did you
just not love this out with your teeth
what does your research say
about america's aspirations as we go
into the new year well one of the things
is to have an aspirational product and
when you do that a lot of people will
move up the spectrum so instead of just
getting the aspiration they'll go over
for say the five dollar organic turkey
so you often use that as a way to
increase people's bananas and then do
you suggest and one of the things i
learned this in frankfurt germany
sitting in a bar with our wonderful
heather harris
that people in germany will save
everything just to buy the bmw or the
mercedes right now we're saving
everything to buy the fancy iphone i
mean do we see a shift in overall
american consumption because we aspire
to stephanie's turkey or to an iphone 6
plus well there is what you're seeing in
consumer trends is people either buying
high or low
the middle is getting squeezed out so
you are seeing people who are really
dedicated by the best very quickly
around the table dark meat light meat
dark meat tofurky
and i'm not saying traduckin white meat
white meat i'm dark meat as well i love
i get a heritage turkey just for the
dark mate
with that turkey i don't really think
this is
talking about
are you really going to eat it
definitely not i'm going to be eating
stuffing without meat and cranberries
just so you know just
in south america